et voilà nous sommes de retour sur
france 3 centre val de loire facebook
merci de nous rejoindre pour ce festival
terres du son on est au sud de tours au
domaine de candé amont et avec une
petite surprise pour vous maintenant
vous allez reconnaître ce tube très
facile évidemment puisqu'on va converger
vers la musique électro pop maintenant
avec le groupe si nab son merci d'être
avec nous alexandre épaules vous l'avez
trouvé comment votre point de
convergence tous les deux voilà on a mis
beaucoup de temps déjà le trouver on se
connaît depuis plus de vingt ans le
projet existe depuis huit ans mais voilà
ça a mis beaucoup de temps parce qu'on
vient d'univers musicaux complètement
différent mais je pense que convergent
c'était justement le moment où on s'est
enfin trouvée donc pour répondre à la
question ses amis un petit peu de temps
mais quel est le déclic justement qui
vous a permis de vous lancer dans un duo
électro rêve d'enfant et quand on s'est
retrouvés à paris
tous les deux dans la même ville s'il ya
huit ans enfin on a vraiment commencé à
s'y mettre on avait déjà des activités
liées à la musique mais de façon non
professionnelle chacun de notre côté et
a eu tant qu'on se retrouvait dans la
même ville du coup sa facilité les
choses pour pour commencer à mettre en
place son avec cet album donc
convergence qui est la concrétisation de
cette symbiose musicale un album dans
lequel vous avez demandé à l'artiste
anna covan interprété le titre en ligne
ou convient d'écouter il ya quelques
instants comment vous avez choisi cette
chanteuse alors interprété créer un ciel
qui a écrit les paroles
on cherchait une voix masculine au
départ on n'a pas trouvé
on a fait des essais ça n'a pas
fonctionné et puis à notre ancien
directeur artistique chez parlophone qui
nous a proposé donc de faire un test
avec un art et ça a été un peu le coup
de foudre
de cette année là où on a sorti
convergence et elle nous a fait un essai
c'était le bon et on n'a pratiquement
rien changé mais à part qu'est les
récrés un couple s est allé vraiment
très vite et de manière très naturelle
quelle manière vous composez vos
morceaux on a aujourd'hui ça a un peu
évolué ça aussi aujourd'hui on a chacun
un studio et ça fait huit ans qu'on
travaille contrat et la musique de deux
syllabes sont donc on sait bien ce qui
je pense qu'il faut faire et ce qui sert
au mieux le projet donc avec ce composé
son côté je compose du mien on a chacun
nos spécificités
mais les idées parts de l'un de l'autre
on finalise tous ensemble vous ne
travaillez jamais en sont en fait dans
un seul et même studio que pour
finaliser et quand on enregistre les
voies etc
mais les idées les débuts de compos non
c'est chacun son côté il est toujours
vous mettre d'accord au final
d'ajustement depuis qu'on a atteint ce
point de convergence on en arrive à à
composer inconsciemment l'un pour
l'autre
on compose pour l'entité synapses ont
donc on sait forcément fin naturellement
dès que je compose quelque chose je sais
que ça plaira à paul et il est très rare
aujourd'hui que l'un envoie une maquette
à l'autre et que le design ans c'est pas
trop mon truc quand vous avez appris à
mixer mixer le faire même génération
mais nous à la base on n'est plus
producteur que dj tous alors ce soir en
est on
le festival terres du son en live
vraiment avec les instruments on est on
est pas tous les deux on a nos musiciens
ou chanteurs et tout ça est en fait le
le fait de mixer de le côté didier c'est
plus qu'au début on n'avait pas les
moyens ni technique ni financier
justement de mettre en place en live
qu'on va présenter ce soir
du coup la façon la plus la plus
évidente est plus facile pour nous
c'était de dalé la mixer en club ou quoi
avec des platines du coup c'est comme ça
que ça a vraiment émergé qu'aujourd'hui
certains beaucoup beaucoup de gens font
encore l'amalgamme de nous qualifier dj
mais on était plus producteurs vendent à
didier c'est important de le souligner
est effectivement et de ça lorsque vous
faites concrètement au sein de synapses
on vous qualifiez votre musique de deep
house qu'est ce que c'est on qualifiait
on qualifie pu parce que la deep house
down est d'abord pascal était à l'époque
ou non la découverte en tout cas ce
qu'elle représentait pour nous
voilà on qualifier de deep house deep
parce que c'était sur un tempo l'un de
tes paulhan pardon et house parce qu'on
aimait avoir une couleur de son quelque
chose d'assez moelleux et et bien porté
par la basse etc
aujourd'hui on fait une musique une
musique éclectique
voilà pour inventer un mot crc de la
musique électronique parce que les
rythmiques sons électroniques et
éclectique parce que on a épuisé notre
influence dans plein de styles de
musique différents vérifier ce soir un
sur scène puisqu'il y aura t saab et
sirius tréma qui est compositeur
guitariste interprète et beat assaillant
rappeur effectivement on voit bien que
vous n'êtes pas un duo tels que l'on
veut le faire croire en fait très
souvent ça apprend on à un dieu dans le
chef d'orchestre mais on prend plaisir
vraiment sera accompagné en live par par
ces artistes là qui a carrément une
vraie plus value c'est impensable en
fait pour vous finalement d'être seul
sur scène si puisque le il ya des médias
les morceaux ou qu'on fait que tous les
deux sur scène on a aussi ramené pas mal
de choses on est un peu essayé de
recréer un studio alex à tous ces
synthétiseurs j'aimais batterie mais
machine tout ça mais voilà c'est ça
c'est quand le fait de faire venir des
invités je pense que c'est ça rend
encore plus vivant certains titres et il
ya un côté un peu de voir partager ce
que nous on a vécu en studio quand on a
créé ces morceaux là on leur fait sur
scène comme voilà quoi comme si des gens
ils étaient donc ces 52 c'est d'offrir
au public aussi le public attend ça
aussi finalement de voir celle de ceux
qui incarnent les paroles que l'on
entend dans vos morceaux
oui oui tout à fait mais c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que donc il ya ces
chanteurs il ya aussi des musiciens
parce que sérieuses et plus guitariste
kiné chanteur en tout cas sur le live et
marinous et
et très très très très forte et
interprète les morceaux qu'il a composés
qu'elle a écrit mais également d'autres
morceaux de l'album ce soir c'est la
première fois vous participent à ce
festival terres du son centre val de
loire
oui c'est la première fois même dans la
région de tours on est on n'a pas fait
énormément de concerts l'an dernier
pourtant on a effet on pense avoir fait
tous les festivals de france et il en
reste quelques-uns et donc là ce soir on
est on est très contents d'être là
surtout que le lieu a l'air très sympa
première impression ce que venait juste
d'arriver là voilà on s'est arrêté à
l'hôtel mais de manière assez brève
on a dû rester dix minutes mais en effet
le pied là là à paris fait et en aidant
les qui fait très chaud en france à
paris fait encore plus chaud et ça fait
plaisir de respirer un air qui est on va
dire vous allez trop frais parce que
vous allez jouer très tardivement ce
soir après minuit voilà c'est ça 23h45
minuit est ce que vous êtes plutôt
scènes extérieures comme ce soir où des
grandes salles type zénith par exemple
on a eu la chance de faire les deux on
aime les deux c'est vraiment différent
je sais pas si on préfère une puisque
l'autre quand il fait beau on préfère
être dehors le jour où il pleut on est
content et dans un zénith mais non
franchement il n'y a pas de les deux ont
en fait la salle on a plus l'impression
de monde on va dire alors voici six à
cinq mille personnes dans un zénith
vraiment beaucoup de monde alors que
s'il y a
trois personnes deux mondes mais on les
sent moins les gens que dans une salle
que c'est beaucoup plus étendue et à
ciel ouvert donc on ressent moins
évidemment l'ambiance entre guillemets
même s'il y en a un c'est ce qu'on verra
donc ce soir à partir de 23 heures 45
pour ce festival terres du son 2007
merci pour les élections d'avoir été
avec nous sur france 3 centre val de
loire et puis on se retrouvera donc tout
le week end évidemment avec d'autres
artistes qui seront avec nous ici au sud
de tours au domaine de candé amont à
plus tard